did you order the code red i don't care
i did the job
you're goddamn right i did yes
we both know you can't shout in court
the witnesses aren't going to shout the
lawyers aren't going to shout
but it's so good it's so good
[Music]
there's always been one legal movie i've
never wanted to do because i don't have
an expertise in military law a few good
men did you order the code red but i
called in some air support the scowl owl
to my legal eagle spencer devin good to
be here
uh spencer you know
in my experience on the internet it
seems like everyone has an expertise in
military law and military tactics what
makes you qualified to talk about a few
good men well i suppose it might be that
i was a judge advocate in the marine
corps for a few years okay so you were a
judge advocate uh but
you know it's not like you saw a combat
or anything right well in addition to
that i was an artillery officer and a
joint terminal attack controller in the
marines yeah sure but then you retired
to some cushy big firm job right well in
addition to all that i'm also a deputy
district attorney on the pacific
northwest where i'd prosecute major
felony crimes okay internet if you take
issue with anything that spencer says
please send your objections to spencer
gmail.com all right let's do it let's
get into a few good men let's do it well
that doesn't sound right
[Applause]
i assume the marines are doing this like
all day long
you know you wake up at 4 30 in the
morning zero 4 30 maybe you brush your
teeth definitely going to shave and then
you immediately go out and do 16 hours
of silent drill
this is what makes us the premier
fighting force in the world
and devin if it's not clear this is the
military equivalent of breakdance
fighting
could it be i mean
that's
that's confidence inspiring you know i'm
just going to point out here that uh
it's pretty common actually that the
silent drill platoon does their uh
morning workout right in front of the
jag headquarters in washington dc
there's a synergistic relationship
between the two entities and it's
historical and hard to describe we'd
have to do a whole different video about
it now they're they're introducing the
judge advocate general core what is that
so in most branches of the uh the us
military we have uh separate cores which
are made up of officers who are lawyers
and those are the judge advocate general
corps of the jag corps captain i
appreciate you seeing me on such short
notice would you like to sit down
uh i'm fine sir have a seat
okay
these are members of the navy
and we're dealing with a potential
criminal situation that happened on a
marine corps base with marines this
actually takes place aboard a naval base
naval base guantanamo and so because
it's a naval base ultimately the navy
has authority over what's happening on
board that base okay so in case you
don't remember the movie here what
happens is uh a soldier is killed uh
during a
hazing process two marines are accused
uh dawson and downey and this whole
movie is more or less going to hinge on
whether these two soldiers were
ordered to do this hazing process the
code red or whether they did it
themselves
on their own initiative and david i'm
just going to interrupt you real quick
before your comment section overflows
with really angry marines uh you just
described them as soldiers and that's
about as worse as sin as you could
possibly oh no oh god worse than murder
worse than espionage
you do not call marine soldiers
you just don't do it all right uh how
should i have referred to them just
refer to them as marines i knew that was
gonna be the god's children god's awful
little children what would you call uh
someone in the navy
sailor ah crap okay all right would you
call someone in the army a soldier yes
okay
and then you call them airmen in the air
force and then uh the coast guard
still working on that i think they call
themselves guardians or guards no it's
not guardsmen because that would be
national guard so i think it's guardians
i think they call themselves guardians
okay
excuse me sorry i'm late
all right danny i know you don't have a
good excuse so i won't force you to come
up with a bad one thank you sir
this first one's for you
seems you're moving up in the world
been requested by division guantanamo
bay cuba a marine corporal named dawson
illegally fires around from his weapon
pfc william santiago threatens to rat on
dawson dawson and pfc loudon downey go
into santiago's room
tie him up stuff a rag down his throat
attending physicians says the rag was
treated with some kind of toxin meantime
go and see lieutenant commander joanne
galloway
with internal affairs
okay so does it make any sense in this
context that he's going to work with
internal affairs the the demi moore
character
so
to the extent that there's something
called internal affairs in this movie uh
i've never heard of it before maybe it
exists but
it the reality of the situation is the
way that the military works everyone is
internal affairs all the time
one of the people we'll be seeing down
there is the barrack ceo colonel nathan
jessup i assume you've heard of him
who hasn't
he's been in the papers lately he's
expected to be appointed director of
operations of national security council
really okay
now i can chime in on this one how often
do you hear about a colonel in the news
in general unless they have committed
some horrible crime i mean the answer is
basically never there's no reason why
anyone would have heard of the jack
nicholson character uh colonel nathan
jessup at this point i'll get them to
drop the conspiracy and conduct i'm
becoming 12 years
so i think it's important to say here
the conduct unbecoming this is really
the first instance that we see it in
this movie um we are dealing with a
lance corporal and a private we don't
have a lot of expectations for conduct
when it comes to lance corporals and
privates we kind of expect them to do
really stupid stuff
it's just that we expect their
non-commissioned officers and their
officers to deal with it they're just
children mr simpson the unfortunate
reality is if that charge did exist
every single marine under the rank of
corporal would be in a lot of trouble
commander do you have some sort of
jurisdiction here that i should know
about my job is to make sure that you do
your job i'm special counsel for
internal affairs so my jurisdiction's
pretty much in your face
but that's what i want to know what is
internal affairs supposed to be doing in
the context of this movie
no one knows the answer to that question
no one knows tell your friend not to get
cute down there
the marines in guantanamo are fanatical
that doesn't make any sense
no that makes no sense at all uh there
is no reason why the marines in
guantanamo bay cuba would be fanatical
the only fanatics really are probably
the entire base of camp lejeune north
carolina as well as camp horno and camp
pendleton where no one can hear you
scream yeah that doesn't make any sense
this is this is peace time and there
aren't any terrorists at guantanamo this
is before the the war on terror well not
just that this is after the cold war uh
this is this film was made in 1992
if they're fanatical they're fanatically
bored
i wanted to provide you with information
about legal fence line shooting that
occurred the night of august the second
i want to know what we're going to do
about this
i think santiago should be transferred
off the base immediately he's that bad
huh
transfer santiago
let's transfer the whole squad off the
base let's
on second thought windward
let's transfer the whole windward
division off the base
i could watch jack nicholson chew the
scenery all day long it's just it's a
master class in ridiculous acting and i
absolutely love it yeah but sort of like
tim burton's joker in the colonel's
uniform it's amazing yeah sir code red
is a disciplinary engagement what's that
mean exactly sir marine falls out of
line it's up to the men in this unit to
get him back on track what's a garden
variety code red
sir
harold you say sir and i turn around and
look for my father
danny daniel kathy
absolutely not
absolutely not under no circumstances is
that okay no
just know any enlisted marine is going
to refer to an officer as sir or ma'am
period and a story this this actually i
will say this this perfectly
encapsulates lieutenant caffey's
character he has no concept of wearing
the uniform he has no concept of what it
means to be an officer he has no concept
of what it means being in the military
did you assault santiago with the intent
of killing him no sir what was your
intent to train him sir
okay but here's the thing
this is the crux of the movie
if you only intended to beat him up and
he died that's still
one of the varieties of homicide yeah
you're engaging in incredibly reckless
conduct and you're causing the death of
someone else through assault
so it is it's not a great line here
what do you know about code reds
before you go get yourself into trouble
tomorrow i think you should know the
platoon commander lieutenant jonathan
kendrick held a meeting with the men and
specifically told them not to touch
santiago
are you familiar with a code red so
there's i'll say this that term code red
i think that may either have been
invented for the purpose of this movie
or it was a term that was used back in
the day
nowadays we just use the term hazing and
hazing is a pretty big deal
and the marine corps and other branches
have been working really hard at taking
hazing out of the equation have you ever
ordered a code red i have never
i mean i've i've done have you ordered a
code red i did what was requested have
you ever ordered a code red you're
goddamn right i did
danny kendrick can i call you john
no you may not
have i did something to offend you
no i like all you navy boys every time
we got to go someplace to fight you
fellas always give us a ride
well that's a pretty classic one well
done to the scriptwriter the u.s navy
the u.s marine corps taxi service
there's a platoon meeting on september 6
at four in the afternoon
lieutenant kendrick says that he gave
strict instructions that nothing was to
happen to santiago man that's correct
and what happened then lieutenant
kendrick came to our room man lieutenant
kendrick ordered us to give santiago a
code red
okay so the way that they're describing
a code red here sounds super illegal it
sounds like hazing and i assume there
are rules against that are marines
required to follow illegal orders
assuming that that is an illegal order
no um so this is where it becomes
complicated
the reality is it's a defense to say i
was ordered to do something but there
are exceptions and the exception is it's
not a defense if you either know that
the order is unlawful or a person of
ordinary sense and understanding would
have known the orders to be unlawful and
now to be clear it's not a person you're
not grabbing someone off the street it's
someone in that culture a marine a
soldier what have you if you're not
permitted to question orders then what's
a secret
huh
what are the magic words i give orders
every day nobody we have softball games
and marching bands they work at a place
where you have to wear camouflage or you
might get shot by the cubans
yeah
i need you
you're better at research than i am and
you know how to prepare a witness
i mean any law student should know how
to do legal research and any trial
lawyer should know how to prep a witness
and what is he really saying that his
strengths are i mean what is he saying
talking good he can't i don't really
know what his strengths are at this
point except that he's tom cruise well
that is that is a big big plus there
this is our defense intent no one can
prove there is poison on the rag code
red they're common and accepted in
guantanamo bay the order a kendrick gave
it b they had no choice but to follow it
they're creating a theme of their
defense they have three different
holes that they're trying to poke in the
prosecution's case and they're they're
taking deeper dives into the strategy of
each one so that they can fold that into
the rest of the trial it's not not
terrible right and and the reality is
you know if they're only charged with
premeditated murder and that's the only
theory that the that the government is
going with on this one then focusing on
that intent could be a home run they
might be winning on that one depending
of course on lesser included offenses
like unpremeditated murder and
manslaughter and what have you
but then focusing on the code red and
the order is also really important
exactly for that reason that following
orders can sometimes be a defense and if
they can say code reds are super common
down in guantanamo bay
then they may be able to say
they thought that it was a legal order
and any ordinary person down there would
have thought it was legal i've been
trying to track down a lieutenant
colonel matthew andrew marcus doctor was
there any sign of external damage no
unauthorized brakes no
cuts no
bruises broken bones no
doctor was there any sign of violence
you mean other than the dead body
[ __ ] i'm walking at every goddamn time
so i think this is not bad
cross-examination prep and it's
something that a lot of lawyers forego
you got a red team your own cases and
your own witnesses and this is you know
prepping for the cross-examination of
the doctor who's going to be a hostile
witness and who doesn't want you to be
able to poke holes in his medical
opinion regardless of whether he thinks
they're innocent or not
and you can't ask these kind of
questions that just set you up for a
softball for you know a hostile witness
to just jump jump all over the accused
entered the barracks room of their
platoon mate pfc william santiago they
woke him up tied his arms and legs with
tape and forced a rag into his throat
a few minutes later a chemical reaction
called lactic acidosis caused his lungs
to begin bleeding
he drowned in his own blood and was
pronounced dead at 37 minutes past
midnight these are the facts of the case
and they are undisputed all right so
uh maybe a slightly argumentative
opening statement but he is talking
about the things that he is going to
prove uh in the course of this trial
talking about what witnesses are going
to testify to and
highlighting the fact that a lot of
these facts are not disputed by either
side so some of the stuff is going to be
a slam dunk and i like that he's
actually using the lectern that is
between council table which is generally
where you would be giving these kinds of
things not running all over the
courtroom in the well in front of the
jury and all that kind of stuff
that's right
the story i just told you and of course
now he's in the well of the court
without permission and it's the exact
same story you're going to hear from
private down
now lieutenant cathy
is going to try and pull off a little
magic act here and this is where it
starts going off the rails
when you start talking about what the
defense is going to do and start talking
about magic acts and things like that
you're losing it because you're no
longer focusing on what you're going to
do what you're going to prove and how
you're going to prove this beyond a
reasonable doubt
now you're just playing into the
defense's hands essentially and when we
get to the end all the magic in the
world will not have been able to divert
your attention from the fact that
wheelie santiago is dead
and dawson and downey
kill them you can get close to the jury
if that's really what you want to do but
man invading their personal space
especially when as kevin bacon's
character is just a captain
i saw on that panel that there are
people who outrank him and do you really
want to start getting close to them
sharing their breathing space spittle
coming out of your mouth and hitting
them no you don't give them some
breathing room be the professional and
don't do that
look up cafe
there was no poison on the rack stand up
dude
prove otherwise is futile because it
just ain't true
when dawson and downey went into
santiago's room that night he wasn't
dead no no stop walking it wasn't to
kill her harm and it wasn't because they
were looking for kicks on a friday night
it's because it was what they were
ordered to do now out in the real world
that means nothing and here at the
washington navy yard
doesn't mean a whole lot more
but if you're a marine
assigned a rifle security company
windward guantanamo bay cuba
and you're given an order you follow it
where you pack your bags the the most
condescending thing you can say that oh
following orders doesn't matter
in the united states but it does when
you're in guantanamo bay in peacetime
well right because remember the marines
down in guantanamo are fanatical
notoriously so you know tom cruise's
character is a navy officer and he's
speaking in a way that perhaps navy
officers would but remember on that
panel are a bunch of marines as well and
they're probably listening to this
thinking this guy has no idea what the
hell he's talking
commander is it possible
for a person to have an affliction some
sort of condition
which might also speed up the process of
acidosis
it's possible
there would still be symptoms though
what kind of symptoms
there are hundreds of chest pains
yes shortness of breath yes fatigue
of course
doctor is this your signature
yes it is would you read your
handwritten remarks at the bottom of the
page please sir
initial testing negative patient
complains of chest pains shortness of
breath and fatigue i'm getting that
witness to say exactly what he
said at some previous time
is perfect in your professional medical
opinion
was willy santiago poisoned your honor
we renew our objection to commander
stone's testimony and ask that it be
stricken from the record we further
asked the court to instruct the court
members to lend no weight to this
witness's testimony the objections of a
rule council you're honored the defense
strenuously objects and requests an 802
conference so that his honor might have
an opportunity to hear discussion before
ruling on this objection the objection
of the defense has been heard and
overruled move to reconsider your
objection is noted the witness is an
expert and the court will hear his
opinion you're not supposed to object to
everything you can really seem like the
jerk when you're making this
long-speaking objection that's totally
unnecessary and it's it's very clear
she's not doing what everybody else
wants her to do in this particular
situation strength strenuously objecting
oh wow strenuously objective i should
take some time to reconsider including
the judge you you know he's he's kept a
pretty tight lid on things but you do
not want to get a judge into that kind
of behavior you're it's only downhill
from there your tenant do you know what
a code red is
yes i do have you ever ordered a code
red no i have not
i mean so this is what's really
dangerous about testifying under oath is
that that's probably not true he's
probably ordered a bunch i mean the the
prior
uh marine
that the code reds are happening all the
time i would call so many rebuttal
witnesses they're like yeah kendrick
told me to order code red on this day
and this day and this day and just
destroy his credibility an officer in
his position he may not be the one
directly ordering code reds on kind of a
day-to-day basis and so the people who
are probably pushing the code reds in
this film at least
are the corporals uh the sergeants
and maybe even some lance corporals now
we object to this entire line of
questioning the government's objection
is sustained lieutenant caffey and i
would remind you that you are now
questioning a marine officer with an
impeccable service record so
what
what
why would the judge make that comment
that is commenting on the evidence by
actually explicitly talking about this
guy's performance evaluations also how
does this judge even know this
lieutenant's performance evaluations
there's nothing wrong with asking
pointed questions of a marine officer i
mean they're not gods can dawson
determine on his own which orders he's
going to follow no he cannot why did you
go to private santiago's room on the
night of september 6th
a code red was ordered by my platoon
commander lieutenant jonathan james
kendrick
thank you do marines have a fifth
amendment right not to testify
absolutely yeah you have the same right
at a trial at a court martial you do not
have to take the stand you can if you
want to
the panel members are going to be
instructed exactly like a civilian
criminal trial that he has a right to
remain silent and you can't take into
consideration whether they choose not to
testify did you ever actually hear
lieutenant kendrick order of code red
well
hal said that private did you ever
actually hear lieutenant kendrick order
a code red
no sir please the court i'd like to
request a recess in order to confer with
my client there's a couple of things
here uh this is a great example of why
you shouldn't object every time you can
because it really you know puts an
exclamation point on like oh something
happened that i didn't like as far as
that private goes it actually
strengthens his case but here's where it
gets even worse remember this is a
co-defendant trial
these two are at trial at the same time
oh and they're represented by the same
they're represented by the same defense
attorneys and right now their interests
materially conflict
also let's talk about witness
preparation for a second you know how to
prepare a witness
the way in which
this most vital piece of information can
get overlooked so that the first time
that we're hearing about it is on
cross-examination
that is a failure yeah an absolute
failure
how are you feeling
well i think
jessup's gonna have his hands full today
listen danny
when you're out there today
if
you feel like it's not gonna happen
you feel like he's not gonna say it
don't go for it
you could get in trouble
i'm special counsel for internal affairs
and i'm telling you you could get in a
lot of trouble okay they keep making an
issue here that like he can't go after
colonel jessup because it's illegal it's
attacking a superior officer and
something is terrible is going to happen
if he
strenuously cross-examines jessup after
falsely accusing a highly decorated
marine officer of conspiracy and perjury
lieutenant cathy will have a long and
prosperous career teaching
typewriter maintenance at the rocco
colombo school for women is that a thing
no no i i don't know what the hell this
is about i think this is as far as i can
tell just some drama generation from
hollywood
if you have an adverse witness on the
stand you are allowed to question them
probably ethically required to yes go
after that absolutely
defense calls colonel nathan jessup
colonel when you learned of santiago's
letter to the nis you had a meeting with
your two senior officers is that right
yes
at present colonel markinson is dead is
that right objection i'd like to know
just what the defense counsel is
implying objection i'd like to know what
opposing opposing counsel is doing
not an objection no just uh hey can you
give me your trial strategy up front
please i don't know what it is your
honor make him tell me
yeah that's a that's a little known fact
in the uniform code of military justice
you're required to trade trial strategy
memoranda
yeah i mean it's it's weird but you know
currently the time of this meeting you
gave lieutenant kendrick in order is
that right i told kendrick to tell his
men that santiago wasn't to be touched
and did you give an order to colonel
markinson as well
i ordered markinson to have santiago
transferred off the base immediately why
i felt his life might be in danger once
word of the letter got out
grave danger
is there anything is there another kind
it just occurred to me why i know the
dialogue in this scene particularly well
obviously this is one of the greatest
courtroom scenes of all time
however uh i
i know the dialogue extremely well
because when i was in high school i
would do speech competitions and every
year someone
like the duo category with two people
would do a recreation of this
cross-examination
and so like i heard this every weekend
for years on end was that the first
flight off the base the o600 was the
first flight off the base
well you flipped to washington earlier
this morning is that right
yes i noticed you're wearing your class
a dress uniform for your appearance in
court today no he's not wearing his
class a dress uniform those are his
service
alphas
thank you very much though mr navy man
did you wear that uniform on the plane i
wore utilities on the plane you brought
your dress uniform with you yes
toothbrush shaving kit change of
underwear your honor is the colonel's
underwear a matter of national security
gentlemen
you better get somewhere fast with this
lieutenant yes sir colonel he's so
clearly laying a foundation for
something like come on like stop
objecting like let him just go get on
with it yeah and and again this is not
like this has been dragging on for 45
minutes he's been on the stand for like
30 seconds yeah
i brought a change of clothes and some
personal items
thank you
santiago's barracks room was sealed off
in its content's inventory four pairs
camouflage pants three long sleeve khaki
shirts three pairs of boots
four pairs green socks three od green
t-shirts please record is there a
question anywhere in our future i'm
wondering why santiago wasn't packed a
classic way of doing exactly the same
thing but with even more power would be
to lay the foundation for the document
that he's reading also i don't think
he's entered that document into evidence
but let's assume that he did
giving it to the witness
and say read this section do you want
the witness to be saying the words that
you want them to say yep yeah exactly
your honor these are the telephone
records from gitmo for september 6th and
these are 14 letters
that santiago wrote in nine months
requesting in fact begging for a
transfer i guess it's not an evidence
we're just gonna have to
take your word for it
the fact is there was no transfer order
santiago wasn't going anywhere isn't
that right colonel objection your honor
it's obviously lieutenant caffey's
intention this afternoon is to smear a
high-ranking marine officer in the
desperate hope that the mere appearance
of impropriety will win in points with a
court member that is not an objection no
i mean well it's a speaking objection
that has no basis whatsoever as far as i
can tell and also
you're you're telling the jury that he's
scoring points against your witness this
this objection this witness is being
torn to shreds your honor we need to put
a stop to it like no stop it
now it's my recommendation sir the
lieutenant cathy be reprimanded for his
conduct and the witness be excused with
the court's deepest apologies the
defendant's rights notwithstanding of
course
and let's just execute the defendants in
your honor
i've had enough of this trial in due
process lieutenant kendrick ordered the
code red didn't he because that's what
you told lieutenant kendrick to do i'm
jeff when it went bad you cut these guys
loose your honor you are
inside the phone transfer your honor you
doctored the logbook
yeah and now we're badgering and being
argumentative did you order the code you
don't have to answer that question i'll
answer the question
you want answers i think i'm entitled
you want answers i want the truth you
can't handle the truth you don't want
the truth because deep down in places
you don't talk about at parties you want
me on that wall you need me on that wall
the fence at guantanamo is
probably a really sleepy place
yeah about as sleepy as a posting as you
can get otherwise i mean imagine that he
was a marine security guard commander at
one of those nuclear bases in seattle or
something like that
using this exact same you want me on
that chain link fence that's right you
need me in front of that nuclear power
plant don't get me wrong it's important
work it needs to be done but the stakes
are not this high
deep down inside you need me to guard
the 7-eleven
[Laughter]
i don't give a damn what you think you
are entitled to so did you order the
code red i don't care i did the job
you're goddamn right i did yes
we both know you can't shout in court
the witnesses aren't going to shout the
lawyers aren't going to shout
but it's so good it's so good there's a
reason why this is a classic
and it's that jack nicholson is in this
movie for like five minutes
it's
the movie is two and a half hours long
he's in the movie for like five minutes
and it's like the greatest acting role i
think of all time i think there's an
argument for that i mean reasonably i
think you watch this movie for this
scene
i mean really it's a classic because of
this
it's amazing
no notes but again
what happens here at this point he may
invoke his right to remain silent
and what happens with the rest of the
court martial i have a suggestion
a few good men too
a few
better men you know if we can do top gun
too we can do a few
okay so we both agree
may not be realistic but this movie
rules but we are still going to give
this movie a grade for legal realism
[Music]
spencer take it away uh how realistic is
it you know it this is a tough subject
matter military justice is not what most
people know or understand i'm just gonna
go ahead and say i give it an a minus i
mean it's it's not perfect but it's
pretty dang close and they get a lot of
little details right yeah i agree this
movie has its flaws but it friggin rules
and another thing that rules is being
able to watch a longer version of this
video which you can do with today's
sponsor nebula and curiosity stream on
nebula my videos always come out early
with zero ads and i release exclusive
content all the time like the director's
cut of this video that you're watching
right now a new video on things people
misunderstand about the constitution why
nfts are bad for creators anti-slap laws
and my first full-length documentary bad
law words good which is honestly
hilarious all this content can only be
found on nebula in fact my friends post
tons of exclusive content too like real
engineering's entire d-day series and
half as interesting's crime spree where
they try to break as many silly laws as
possible across the united states now
all of this exclusive content is only on
nebula which you can get for free with
curiosity stream and by the way we've
been developing nebula like crazy nebula
now has apps for ios android apple tv
roku fire tv and android tv my fellow
creators and i really care about nebula
and we're thrilled to be partnering with
curiosity stream because they are the
go-to source for the best documentaries
and long-form educational content on the
internet and they even have an entire
section devoted to unsolved mysteries
and crime so if you like my videos
you'll love the stuff on curiosity
stream now the best way to get access to
nebula and all the incredible content is
through the amazing curiosity stream
nebula bundle deal with its current
sales price of less than 15 per year to
get full access to both sites and to be
clear that nebulous subscription is not
a trial it's free for as long as you're
a curiosity stream member there just
isn't a better deal in streaming where
you get two great streaming sites with
content that you'll actually watch and
enjoy for less than fifteen dollars per
year at the current sales price and
what's more signing up will actually
help countless independent educational
creators beyond just legal eagle so sign
up now by clicking on the button that's
on screen right now or you can click on
the link that's in the description it's
a great way to support educational
content and get tons of exclusive
content that you'll actually love so
click on the link that's on screen right
now or you can click on this playlist
over here with all my other youtube
videos so click on this playlist or i'll
see you in court